my name is Joel strong I am a satirical
photographer and I make stop motion
videos with the pictures I take using
forced perspective and little cutouts
this is a project called heads of state
the idea was to show the frontrunners of
the presidential race their ordinary
lives I imagine their lives are pretty
chaotic right now on the campaign trail
and I wanted to take them out of that
chaos and put them you know like on the
playground or taking in these river
ferry
so yeah so sometimes people ask me why I
do this the way I do it the short answer
is I can't do it the other way I don't
know after-effects and to do it this way
though I also find that more rewarding
to capture everything in frame and to
know I got it and I made an effect that
was harder and I had to craft something
I had to make it cut out just the right
size in the right way like Donald Trump
taking a leak
you know like some back alley somewhere
is to me funny because that's certainly
not something he would maybe you would
do it but it's not something that you
would do right now first I have to find
a bunch of facial expressions that I
like I cut all those out and I think for
this one there's like 80 to 90 heads
were used